my administration is using the tools
every tool at disposal protect american
families and businesses from rising
prices at the gas pump
you know we're taking active steps to
bring down the cost
and american oil and gas companies
should not should not exploit this
moment to hike their prices is he
threatening a nuclear strike
i have no idea
what he's threatening i know what he has
done number one
number two
no one expected the sanctions to prevent
anything from happening you said in
recent weeks that big nations cannot
bluff when it comes to something like
this you recently said the idea of
personally sanctioning president putin
was on the table is that a step that
you're prepared to take and if not
that's on the table
sanctioning president putin yes why not
sanction him today sir mr president
why not sanction him today
mr president if i can they are profound
sanctions
let's have a conversation in another
month or so to see if they're working
well let's find out in a month and by
the way it was kamala harris that said
that sanctions would
deter vladimir putin that's not a way
forward john mccain actually once said
russia is a gas station masquerading as
a country the only way to really deter
putin and his cronies there is a way to
defeat putin and push him back and it
doesn't require one bullet to be fired
one american boot on the ground it is to
degrade russia's oil and gas
capabilities that is his financial
lifeline now before his speech biden
should have lifted all major
restrictions on all drilling all
fracking all exploration he should have
convened a meeting with america's top
energy producing companies and
encouraged every one of them to produce
energy like never before he should have
lifted every restriction that he imposed
including the permanent hold on new
drilling in alaska and anwar the
suspension of new drilling on all
federal lands and the pause of new
permits for offshore drilling he should
have also made guarantees to supply our
allies with the energy that they need
through american oil american coal and
american liquefied natural gas
that didn't happen today in fact just
the opposite according to the white
house the sanctions are not designed to
cause any disruption
of the flow of russian energy to the
rest of the world translation
joe biden is going to allow putin to
continue to get rich and russia to get
even more rich
under putin under biden even the united
states look at these numbers why are we
importing nearly six over six hundred
thousand barrels of oil from russia
every single day and keep in mind that
the keystone xl pipeline that biden
killed while giving the north stream to
waiver to putin that could pump 830 000
barrels of oil a day
and get this even over a million barrels
of iranian oil were imported last march
the first time since 1991.
now sadly joe will not revive the
keystone xl pipeline he won't encourage
more oil and gas production right here
in the u.s he won't do anything to
increase our production biden takes his
orders from the radical climate alarmist
that is the cult of the democratic new
green deal party in america and right
now on cue biden's climates are there he
is john kerry he's whining that war in
ukraine is it is distracting from his
important mission to save the world from
global warming this is where his mind is
at today take a look
massive
uh emissions consequences to the war but
equally importantly you're going to lose
people's focus you're going to lose
certainly big country attention because
they will be diverted and and i think it
could have a damaging impact so i hope
president putin will help us to stay on
track with respect to what we need to do
for the climate
john he doesn't care about your climate
agenda you have to be a complete idiot
to say what you just said and believe
what you just said and this is the same
guy john kerry flying around the world
in his private jet lecturing we the
american people about our carbon
footprint now clearly the biden
administration they seem to care more
about their radical green agenda
than actual peace and actual security
this is delusional but this is where we
are with war on the european continent
once again and of course the mob in the
media they promised this wouldn't happen
they told us that biden was a foreign
policy expert he put vladimir putin in
his place he's the only one he said that
went toe-to-toe with vladimir in june
world-class idiot jennifer rubin
authored this glowing article in the
washington post entitled the biggest
winner in the biden putin summit
democracy care to take that back anyway
a few months later in december she
proclaimed that biden has effectively
set a red line for putin last week new
york times genius thomas friedman idiot
that he is wrote quote if vladimir putin
opts to back away from invading ukraine
even temporarily it's because joe biden
has matched every putin chess move with
an effective counter of his own
uh no joe's plane checkers and it's
already been checked mate joe doesn't
know it yet three days ago one fake news
cnn analyst tweeted quote whatever
happens in ukraine we shouldn't
underestimate the fact that the u.s
has retaken the adult share in the world
biden has restored american leadership
so damaged by trump the world needs us
and we have a president who can lead and
does lead they must all be high and
hallucinating on some kind of chemical
that we don't have at box because all of
that is garbage and on tuesday stephen
king tweeted mr putin has made a serious
miscalculation he forgot he's no longer
dealing with trump
that's right he's not dealing with trump
he's dealing with the always weak always
predictable the cognitive mess joe biden
and biden once found that he'd go
toe-to-toe with vladimir but now he's
barely willing to play footsie as putin
is now rampaging through a major
european country how far these ambitions
go these territorial ambitions that's
anybody's guess tonight so sadly the
question must be asked where does this
end take a look
did you underestimate putin and would
you still describe him the way that you
did in the summer as a worthy adversary
at the time
he was i made it clear as an adversary
and i said he was worthy i didn't
underestimate him
and i've read most of everything he's
written did you read i shouldn't say i'm
not a wise guy
the you you heard the speech he made
almost an hour's worth of speeches why
he was going into ukraine
he has much larger ambitions in ukraine
he wants to in fact reestablish the
former soviet union that's what this is
about
that's probably right putin does have
ambitions beyond ukraine his next target
could be what the three nato nations in
the baltic region of europe nato members
hmm that'll get interesting then we're
looking at what world war iii unless of
course nato is a paper tiger
which unfortunately i have to report
tonight is probably a real possibility
and sadly we're going to find out one
way or another if biden and europe
failed to get serious and cut off their
addiction to russian oil and gas so far
every indication is that's not on
biden's agenda our own peter ducey
asking the white house press secretary
jensachi if the administration would
ever consider restarting restarting the
keystone xl pipeline here's what she
said take a look
there's this talk about a possible
forecast for financial pain particularly
the gas pump
for americans the president said today
the notion that this is going to last
for a long time is highly unlikely would
he try to ensure that by lifting some of
the restrictions that he's put in place
on the energy industry or
rethinking some projects like the
keystone pipeline
well first of all the keystone pipeline
is not flowing so i'm not sure how that
would solve anything there's also plenty
of oil leases that are not being tapped
into by oil companies so you should talk
to them about that and why
yeah go talk to the oil companies hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else